so you uh you got the new record out
with the baby yeah he spazzed out I love
the White lives matter line that [__]
was hilarious
I'm so appreciative of him though
because he one of the first people who
started [__] my [__] right like he
put I saw him coming on the votes Island
first like
he he they went on that [__] do you like
well first of all shout out to the baby
who's an incredible artist you guys are
our label mates as well what was uh the
process of getting that record done was
it just sending it over you son's in the
school
yeah he's on Interscope yeah I did not
know that yeah no it wasn't even a
process he just was in mind he was in
Miami like where you at I'm like I'm in
Miami he said I'm putting up on you
tonight that's it we just did it it was
on our own type time knocked it out even
with the video like it was we it was
just me and him the whole time that's
amazing because usually you know how it
is with these a lot of bigger artists
there's like the middle man or there's
like I don't like that [__] though right
because I make time for what I want so
was it um as easy of a process to get a
little baby on the vulture Island remix
it was it was really part of the easiest
I ain't had it like we ain't linked up
with nothing it just he just handled it
sent it over
send him the open version and he
returned it returned it did a video
whenever I wanted to do it like and she
was easy do you remember like uh the
first time you realized vulture Island
was like viral
or was like really moving was it like
somebody had posted it or somebody you
saw somebody
like I I never realized but I ain't
gonna lie you're just kind of living in
it I just know it's about not because I
go people listening to it but it's like
I ain't never new episodes all right
yeah everything that would give me that
Vibe like oh yeah we going dumb you know
no no hmm
uh what's up with your boy Zion
Williamson man can we get him on the
basketball court all right line Zion my
love has he tapped in with you yeah
that's my real dog like
you guys are friends yeah it's my red
dog so I ain't got that he'd be back
soon man he just hurt right now how did
you guys connect I mean obviously he's
probably a fan but like um I had to do a
private party
you did it you threw a private party I
threw a private party popped up on me he
seems like a nice guy nah for sure for
sure he's very talented was the he's
just [__] injured all the time I know
he's gonna be straight though I I think
he just I don't know I really don't know
what's up with it all right so like
you're growing up as a kid watching the
Pelicans you probably like at that time
Anthony Davis is like the guy man listen
I'm a real Pelicans fan like Jay-Z said
they go over 82 like hey I appreciate
that because I'm a real Suns fan and the
suns were very bad up until like two
years ago so so you've been riding with
the Pelicans what bro like nobody can't
tell me nothing about the pellet guns
bro through holiday days holiday Chris
Paul like yeah whatever we went through
well when Chris Paul was there it was
the Hornets yeah but I was defense too I
remember they changed to the Pelicans I
had I was like I should have left it at
the harness like the Hornets were fired
the harness was fired while we changed
that bro well y'all got Pelicans out
there though the Pelican flag we don't
got Pelicans bro I saw one pedal wait
there's no Pelicans in [__] New
Orleans I saw one Pelican bro this is
this isn't a try and that was this year
bro this is it was last year bro what a
terrible name for a franchise if there's
no [__] Pelicans they don't even have
hornets out there
I mean we knew that this should have
named the voodoo or something the voodoo
is the voodoo [__] real in New Orleans
yeah this [__] definitely
because you can feel it in there yeah
when you go out there you could smell it
like
it's just it's just a feeling like do
you know [__] out there be
putting Voodoo hexes on [__] or
oh no I don't know I don't think so not
that I know of if there is I would want
to know yeah because I want I want to do
Voodoo People
you would do some voodoo on somebody
yeah for sure you cast a spell yeah good
spell them like what kind you never see
the best would you ever make a like
maybe make a chick Fall in Love with You
cast that spell
my best but just make everything go how
I want to go I think it's it's safe to
say it's going pretty well for you if a
girl fall in love with you bro like me
girlfriend bro you asking you asking for
something that you really don't want bro
girls crazy bro but if you cast a spell
it could be any girl it could be Nicki
JLo you don't want Nikki unless you
needed like bro if a girl that loves you
bro she she brother she crazy bro hmm I
don't want no girl that crazy with me so
you are trying to prevent women from
falling in love with you actively
um
just
not right now it's a cool in love okay
not knowing Voodoo in love Voodoo in
love is like boy I do anything right
that's like Christian rock crazy yeah I
don't like that yeah that's crazy to me
yeah you don't want a girl with your
face tatted on there
yeah that I wouldn't respect that she
tagged up my table right there Christian
rock with a [__] knife
that's her that's her [__] artwork
C plus J forever J is Jonathan blueface
oh she's great
she started a heart
bro it was a [__] I don't have a knife
don't do it with your nail bruh
I tried concerned